if you're one of the people who had a
hard time understanding Tom Hardy as
bane let me introduce you to his
character in lawless have fun lawless is
directed by John Hill code and star Shia
LaBeouf Tom Hardy and Jessica Chastain
Guy Pearce Gary Oldman just a bevy of
incredible actors yes bevy that's a word
it is it takes place during the
Prohibition days when the selling of
alcohol was illegal and there's this
group of brothers Shia LaBeouf Tom Hardy
and some other guys and they all sell
moonshine and they're always running
from the law and you know they're kind
of like the most respected of all of the
illegal traders of alcohol in this area
some members of the law actually accept
it and buy moonshine from them and then
there are others who don't that's Guy
Pearce and his group of guys and they're
gonna stop at nothing to catch them you
may look at that and say well okay
they're try and do the right thing but
no Guy Pearce is one messed up son of a
dirty nasty whore guys Pierce is insane
in this movie he is off-the-chain bad in
this movie and what starts as kind of a
fun movie where you see these brothers
trying to sell alcohol to people turns
into this blood war between these
brothers and the cops led by guy Pierce
no I was looking forward to lawless
because the director of John Hill coat
made the proposition also starring Guy
Pearce and that's one of the best
westerns I've ever seen and lawless was
great this is actually one of my
favorite movies of the year so far I dug
the heck out of this movie it was so
badass immediately as Tom Hardy's
character enters frame in this movie you
automatically like this guy not just
because Tom Hardy is such a good actor
nowadays and I'm really impressed with
him he just keeps giving out these good
performances and he is just the absolute
definition of the strong silent type he
barely says a thing yet everyone looks
that guy he knows if I get on his bad
side he's gonna rip out my jugular I
better not say anything to him and guy
Pearce's character is the one guy who
decides you know what I don't care I'm
going head-to-head with you and I'm
gonna mess up your life there's parts
throughout the movie where there's no
physical action you know where there's
no kicking or explosions or whatever
each scene had so much tension in it and
I always just felt like some guy was
gonna jump out of the bushes and just
rape somebody or something it was just
such a dark land that they were able to
successfully portray in this in this
movie
where there was this time where people
just they wanted their booze man
they did they wanted their booze or they
wanted to stop you from getting yours
let's talk a little bit about the actors
in this movie Shia LaBeouf I really
think that if people give this movie a
chance cuz this isn't really the kind of
movie where everyone just goes it makes
a ton of money but I think if people
give this movie the chance this will be
the movie where people stop thinking of
Shia LaBeouf as the kid from
transformers or as Indiana Jones's son
and they're gonna start thinking of him
as a serious actor because I really
think he was really good in this movie
he didn't do any of the Shia LaBeouf
isms that people constantly attribute to
him he didn't scream every two seconds
he was very subdued I thought he gave a
really good performance as I said Tom
Hardy was really good in this movie he
was funny he was likeable but he was
also extremely intimidating and he
pulled that off really well after a
movie a friend of mine went I really
loved that movie I just wanted more Gary
Oldman I could always have more Gary
Oldman would have been nice to see more
of him in this movie but the scenes that
he had were great he was great in the
movie of course but I want to talk to
you about my favorite performance in
this movie and it's performance that I
honestly think deserves an academy award
nomination Guy Pearce blew me away in
this movie he is one of the best
villains of the year so far he freaking
shaved his eyebrows like Albert Brooks
did for Drive there's a scene in this
movie where you can tell that he had
gotten a prostitute for the night
because it cuts to the morning and the
prostitutes is laying on the bed jizz
crying and he's just doing his hair in
the mirror just greasing back his hair
while this hookers back there crying you
don't know why she's crying she's just
there and he's just looking into the
mirror all calm and he just adjusts his
suit and everything I'm like dude this
is one the best villains of the year I
mean think about it really it's almost
September
how many Academy Award worthy
performances have we seen this year for
men I mean the two biggest ones that
stick out to me the most are Matthew
McConaughey and killer Joe and this
there are some other great performances
I've seen so far this year and it may be
forgetting some people we still have
Academy Award season and all that coming
up Kadim e if you're listening I don't
know if you are but if you are check
that dude out because he deserves it
there are certain elements of it that
are cliched and when I say cliched I
mean they're just familiar and a little
bit implausible I guess is the best word
to describe what happens to certain
characters in this movie and then they
keep getting up and they keep getting up
and they keep getting up and you're like
you should be dead
man yeah there were a few slow parts
where nothing terribly interesting was
happening for the most part I had a
great time with lawless
I had a lot of fun with it it was very
hard-hitting the movie pulled no punches
great performances some really visceral
filmmaking and one of my favorite movies
so far this year I'm gonna give lawless
an a- so I suggest some to you guys
would be check out the proposition if
you happen it is one seriously hardcore
Western if you haven't experienced it I
really think you'd enjoy it a little
slower than lawless but it's a lot of
fun I think and I think you'll enjoy it
Ray Winstone it's also really good in
that movie thanks for watching guys and
as always if you liked this review then
you can click right here and get stuff
mine eyes
[Music]